now in the arena  so that shows you the respect he has  walker for three punches and campbell  walker lighting up the garden here in  the second quarter  the quarter 25 for the half  this is how you return from being in the  doghouse  with the vengeance chance of kendall  walker as he looks to inbound aaron  holiday's gonna come  a lot of the fans on their feet  serenading walker though  randall back to walker walker  stumbles drives off balance oh he puts  it in with 1.3 remaining  abdia  almost put that in from half court  as kimball walker with a brilliant  performance here in the first two  quarters the resurgence continues  22 points in the period 27 for the half  intoxicating people to play by walker  he thinks he's back in the big east  folks  walker here at madison square garden  gives the knicks a six-point lead